of releases in the mold
it generates me I look for freedom this deserves to
be a
writer outside 20 days in moments
of jaén
and
[Music]
yes
it happens to me
we can
the life and work little
west version treat the humidity
aitor de tenis my life
experience
and  that
was a very strong emotion for me
watching on television that they were
there shouting that
they wanted rómulo free that they wanted to dilute his double chin free and
all
thank god you gave me those girls
are so strong
functions no thanks
thank god that is what  that he recorded was
enough for them to know what
was happening and everything because if in that
video I think that nothing would have
happened, nothing would have gone unnoticed
like many
, nothing happens
[Music]
thanks
to the one
if I want it is 41
[Music]
and I did  One year I was in the center of
attention and I was thinking that God would
give me the opportunity to throw a
party for Tim because it was a dream that
she had and I told my first
daughter  just god I'm going to do it for you you're going
to see let's get out of here you're going
to see what we're going to do party
[Applause]
[Music]
of spectators on tour of good
health in general
[Music]
yes
I always get desperate
[Music]
I have a lot of people who support me all of them
studied at the quinceañera I was
very happy that those people who have
supported us still continue to support us follow
behind us and that day I am
enjoying it very much with a
party  The most difficult thing has been because at
the time that I was separated from my
family for six months,
I was looking forward to the day of the visit with
great desire.
We
don't get much time or anything, teacher,
before we start from
scratch, wine
is very difficult for me, what I have is
rather the alfano who asks for your ID
[Music]
iker world hamilton they
still can't stop it they can stop it  ar
they can stop your life, one's life,
but they don't follow, they
don't give up for anything
, it's my daughters' country, but you are in
your country too, which I also love
because of what you have given me  Because of the
opportunities I have had, continue
working, they continue studying,
given the usual routine, but now
with more desire,
I have great faith that everything will work out
[Music]
[Laughter]
[  Laughter]
[Music]
you